welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is an explanation of the
ending of matt reeves the batman
spoilers ahead obviously trust me you're
gonna want to watch this movie as it's
meant to be seen in a theater with amc's
upcharge ticket price but don't worry
here's nicole kidman to tell us
heartbreak feels great in a place like
this the batman proved to be a world's
greatest detective story with an ending
that both leaves us muddy and sets the
stage for the future of this gotham that
includes a major cameo in the second to
last scene which seemed pretty
straightforward but then while there is
no post-credits scene per se there is a
post-credit moment with actually a major
detail that i think a lot of people
overlooked and it's really cool when you
dig into it so let's break it down oh by
the way i am wearing our custom design
gotham noir shirts available for a
limited time at newrockstarsmerch.com
it's really the best way to support us
so in the batman our boy vengeance
discovers that his father passed mayoral
candidate thomas wayne in attempt to
protect his wife martha from the scandal
of her parents murder-suicide and her
subsequent institutionalization thomas
used crime boss carmine falcone to
silence a journalist but falcone went
ahead and killed that journalist to have
leverage over thomas and then thomas and
martha when they were gonna go to the
cops about it ended up murdered but
alfred was never sure whether it was
falcone or just a random murder falcon
is revealed to be el rata aladda the
winged rat the stool pigeon because
falcons have wings the confidential
informant protected by city authorities
really the boss of the whole city
because all these different authorities
stole from thomas's billion-dollar
donation to renew gotham's orphanages
and one of those screwed over orphans
was edward nashton who as the riddler
goes on a murder spree against all these
corrupt leaders including gunning down
falcone and this plan ends up with
nashton flooding the whole city in order
to force people into new mayor bella
real's victory rally where his minions
would gun them all down but batman stops
them using one of his chest emblem
knives to sever a generator that would
have zapped those drenched gothamites
and leads the survivors to safety now
this is all actually a really
well-crafted crime mystery in the style
of seven in chinatown and i will explore
all of this in more detail in my full
movie breakdown coming tomorrow but
after this climax we return to arkham
asylum where edward nashton is growling
in rage in his cell but then a voice
from one cell over speaks out to him
this is actor barry killen seen most
recently as druid in marvel's eternals
but here he's credited only as unseen
gotham prisoner and he says isn't that
just terrible him raining on your parade
like that what is it they say one day
you're on top and the next you're a
clown well let me tell you there are
worse things to be hey hey don't be sad
you did so well and you know gotham
loves a comeback story and then edward
asks who are you barry's character
responds well that's the question isn't
it riddle me this the less of them you
have the more one is worth and edward
answers the riddle a friend and then the
two laugh maniacally
[Laughter]
now it is hard to make out but we
actually see this unseen gotham prisoner
and barry killen's face definitely looks
a bit disfigured his hair frazzled with
a wide grin full of jagged teeth that
plus his laugh and his references to
being a clown clearly make him this
universe's joker remember this is year
two batman so he may have been a
criminal that batman put away in his
first year just not knowing the threat
that the joker truly was or would become
or this joker could have been in the
slammer before bruce became a vigilante
making him a criminal that batman still
has yet to face and there was one really
creepy detail in the riddler's home
earlier in the movie there's a newspaper
photo of bruce wayne that included a
smiling face in the background a smile
that matches the smile of barry cohen so
this joker may have actually been
stalking bruce before he ended up
incarcerated now the film ends with
batman parting ways with selena kyle in
the gotham cemetery selena actually says
she's headed to bloodhaven a city in the
dc universe that neighbors gotham known
to be the base of operations for
nightwing but here she tells batman you
know this place is never gonna change
with carmine gone it's only gonna be
worse for you there's gonna be a power
grab it'll be bloody and she's referring
to how the death of carmine falcone whom
she revealed to be her actual father
opened things up for his second in
command oz cobblepot the penguin to take
over the city's crime and drug operation
drugs in this movie called the drops now
penguin is getting his own spin-off
series on hbo max along with another
series starring jeffrey wright as jim
gordon called gotham pd i'm gonna get
meta for a second read your mind because
i'm pretty sure you are watching this on
some kind of electronic device am i
wrong these magical items that help us
call our moms and subscribe to nerdy
youtube channels well unfortunately when
you throw electronics away they become
e-waste a toxic solid waste that does
gross stuff like leak lead and mercury
into our water so a great way to keep
toxic e-waste out of landfills is by
purchasing renewed electronics and our
friends at back market have built an
amazing marketplace that offers expertly
renewed smartphones laptops and other
tech for a fraction of the normal cost
i've actually been using this sweet 2020
rose gold ipad air from backmarket and i
love it it looks brand new it costs way
less than buying new and it didn't turn
into e-waste i mean look at me i'm being
sustainable while playing the wingspan
app oh the bird chirp sent me every
purchase comes with a one-year warranty
30 days to change your mind and free
standard shipping plus with backmarket's
new buyback program you can also sell
your old tech for cash a refurbished
smartphone prevents 175 pounds of carbon
emissions and prevents 568 pounds of raw
materials from being mined that's a lot
of cow farts and giant holes in the
ground you're preventing just by saving
money on a phone use code rockstar and
save twenty dollars on your first
purchase of expertly renewed tech so
break up with new tech and find your
next device at backmarket.com that's
back market not black market but then
after the credits on the screen blinks
the riddler's question mark cursor from
ratalatta.com the url batman and gordon
used to investigate the riddler in the
film the cursor types out the word
goodbye which seems like a joke don't
close your eyes when you laugh this off
because the screen flickers out briefly
flashing the actual url of ratalata.com
and obsessives like me who have been
following this movie recognize that url
as an actual real-life site where since
december this film has been updating
with actual riddles tying into the movie
that week after week lead to the release
of riddler ciphers that translate to
phrases that each give us a few more
letters of riddler's overall alphabet i
actually made a whole other video
breaking down that timeline and how we
were able to piece together the complete
cipher it was a fascinating journey you
gotta check out that video but as this
movie premiered on wednesday night the
site was updated once more so that fans
who spotted this url in the post-credits
scene and went to the site right after
that would find a series of riddles one
asks i am first a fraud or a trick or
perhaps a blend of the two that's up to
your misinterpretation a fraud or a
trick con a blend of the two fusion so
the answer confusion another asks what
is new is new again rebirth restoration
reformation and you type in the answer
renewal and then fear he who hides
behind one then you type in the answer
mask so that lets you download a zip
file titled what am i asking for a
password and the answer is the answer to
the riddle from the previous week which
included the word imposer an anagram of
which is promise so you plug promise in
and then the zip opens to a 30-second
clip of that dr thomas wayne campaign
video that the riddler played in the
orphanage instilled in both of us
the giving back is not just an
obligation
it's a passion
that is our family's legacy
[Music]
[Music]
and you notice the word hush pops up
there likely a nod to the batman hush
storyline with some thematic parallels
to this film and then there was one more
cipher with the glyphs arranged in a
linear maze path like the ones for you
are el rata elata in the movie but in
this case it spells out maze of riddles
which is significant because it finally
gave us the letter z which we didn't
have before making it the 25th of 26
letters in riddler's overall alphabet as
i explained in the other video the one
letter remaining is j or mr j the joker
that the riddler just became besties
with so while the batman film works
perfectly on its own as a truly chilling
detective story enough doors remain open
for the deeper fans to remain invested
in this expanding world we got the
penguin and his own show taking over the
criminal operation of gotham we got the
gordon his own show investigating this
and other crimes meanwhile in arkham
asylum we got two of batman's greatest
enemies the riddler and the joker
plotting their next move and even matt
reeves said he would love to explore a
grounded mr freeze in this universe what
killed the dinosaurs
guys
so we have bright days ahead or really
dark days ahead now again i'm gonna be
breaking all this down in a full
in-depth easter egg breakdown coming
tomorrow and lots of videos about the
batman coming in the days ahead and
again you can check out our gotham noir
shirt at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me
on instagram and twitter
avos follow new rockstars subscribe to
the rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
batman
[Music]
you